we were just talking you don't know what
make Talent no I thought it was a person
no I have a kind of idea but I'm really
not sure what do you think it is I think
it's to do with like red pill I think I
briefly read somewhere it's like a
movement of men who are I don't know if
it's got anything to do with like
passport Bros that's about the extent of
my knowledge so it's men going their own
way men going there so either there's
different levels some are walking away
from Marriage altogether they basically
looked at the institution and the way
Society set up and say we are
discriminated again we cannot interact
with a woman without there being a legal
consequence